Traduttore: Roberta Zanella
Revisore: Salvo Baglieri
Buonasera
(Applausi)
Ooooh, buonasera io sono Andrea Delogu,
sono una ragazza di trent'anni
da quattro anni più o meno e questa cosa
si protrarrà per altri 4/5 anni, così,
ad occhio, e la mia storia è raccontata
in un libro dal titolo "La Collina",
edito Fandango. Lavoro tutti i giorni,
insomma, vado in diretta in radio
su Radio2, con un programma
che conduco con altri due pazzi.
Dopodiché, faccio parte
del "Processo del lunedì".
Poi conduco "Troppo giusti", un programma
di cinema, ovviamente di Marco Giusti.
E tutto questo per me è bellissimo,
per alcuni di voi, giustamente,
è molto frivolo, però per me è bellissimo
contando che, fino ai 18/19 anni
mi veniva un attacco d'ansia
di fronte a un testo scritto
e che non riuscivo neanche troppo
a parlare bene.
Quindi tutto questo per me è
la realizzazione di un sogno:
la comunicazione a 360 gradi.
Per fare tutto questo, diciamo così,
ho attinto a un segreto,
un segreto che io oggi voglio
condividere con voi.
Ci tengo davvero tanto.
E il segreto è questo.
Questo è il mio segreto.
È un segreto molto
particolare, qualcosa di diverso,
qualcosa che forse...
Ah, scusate, non avete...
non avete capito, non avete letto.
Rimandiamo, non c'è problema.
Questo è il mio segreto.
Non si capisce, vero?
Allora forse così è meglio.
"Ho imparato di più dalla gente
in rete e sui social che a scuola,
perchè sono dislessica"
Era difficile prima, vero?
Un po' frustrante, quando qualcuno
deve leggere in velocità,
o quando qualcuno deve leggere
e voi non capite.
Ecco, pensate che una persona
dislessica, tipo come me,
con questa sensazione ci vive
tutta la vita. Io, per tutta la vita,
mi sono sentita un po' stupida.
Cioè in realtà non è ancora
finita la mia vita quindi anzi
spero di poter andare avanti
per un bel po', però, insomma,
per molti anni mi sono sentita
un po' stupida.
Io vi ho odiato, a ognuno di voi,
anche a voi che ci state guardando
da casa su Periscope.
Io vi ho odiato profondamente
perchè voi sapevate la tabelline,
voi riuscivate a declinare ogni verbo,
voi sapevate leggere in classe,
ed era incredibile,
e io vi odiavo.
Adesso ho smesso di odiarvi,
però prima vi odiavo tantissimo.
E odiavo anche le mie professoresse,
però poi ho capito che non era colpa
poi di nessuno, ecco,
non era colpa vostra,
non era colpa delle professoresse,
anche se, un giorno, alle medie,
se mi ricordo bene, ho perso
il primo posto per un concorso regionale
di temi per i troppi errori,
quindi mi fecero arrivare seconda.
Mi convocò la mia professoressa e
mi disse che si era vergognata tantissimo
nel dover ammettere che era stata
la mia professoressa di italiano.
Questa cosa mi sconvolse, perché,
anche se non ero ancora al corrente
di essere dislessica, pensavo:
"ok, ma mi scusi, ma il tema andava bene,
quindi il tema l'avevo creato io,
il problema erano gli errori,
però gli errori li ho fatti perché lei
non è stata in grado di insegnarmi
che errori non fare.
Quindi il problema non era il mio.
Avrei dovuto rispondere semplicemente
"come si permette professoressa,
l'errore è suo non mio,
per quale motivo mi sta giudicando?"
Ma non lo feci perché come ho detto
poc'anzi, avevo problemi nel parlare.
Infatti, anni dopo, spesi 50 euro l'ora,
per molti mesi, per risolvere
questo piccolo problema della erre,
che adesso mi vanto molto nel dire:
ramazza, correre, rosa.
Ora, 50 euro spesi molto bene.
Grazie, questo era molto importante
ricordarvelo perchè poi i soldi erano
anche dei miei genitori.
Ho cercato di allinearmi un po'
agli standard, quindi ho cercato di
ridimensionare un po' tutti i miei sogni
e, vabbè, questa cosa non è bella,
perchè un bambino dovrebbe sognare sempre
in grande, dovrebbe sempre cercare di
volere il massimo, di fare l'astronauta,
o di fare l'attore famoso, o, che ne so,
di scrivere canzoni migliori,
quelli devono essere i sogni.
Poi ci penserà la vita a dirti
che non ce la puoi fare,
ma un bambino
non può smettere di sognare,
eppure io ero costretta a farlo
perchè non riuscivo, perchè già vedevo
in classe che arrivavo dopo gli altri.
E questa cosa fa male.
Poi, arrivarono insomma i primi test
dove si vedeva che avevo un problema
di apprendimento e allora mi dicevano
"ma dai, Andrea, non ti preoccupare,
un sacco di persone famose ce l'hanno,
hanno avuto problemi di apprendimento,
un sacco di persone famose, tipo queste.
Non riuscivano a leggere bene, come te.
Tipo Leonardo da Vinci,
Einstein, Beethoven."
Io li guardavo e dicevo "scusate, ma
questa cosa mi mette ancora più ansia,
ma che v'aspettate da me?"
Cioè, n'attimo, io non voglio far niente,
cioè io non voglio salvare il mondo,
non voglio vincere dei premi Oscar,
Nobel, io, io vorrei soltanto non avere
degli attacchi di panico davanti
a un foglio scritto.
Era più semplice.
Quindi mi dispiace anche per loro,
magari se ne stanno accorgendo adesso,
ma non mi hanno aiutato, per niente.
Poi arrivò la soluzione, che non furono
i corsi di recupero, perchè quelli me li
fecero fare tutti, ma semplicemente
era un allungare il mio problema,
perché le ore di scuola erano
un grossissimo problema per me,
mi sentivo davvero diversa e
davvero stupida,
e poi, mi ci mandavano al pomeriggio.
Era un inferno la mia vita,
non so se riuscite un attimo a pensarlo.
Quasi 24 ore su 24, perchè poi tornavi
a casa e dovevi dire a tuoi genitori
che non avevi combinato niente.
Ti sentivi inadatto.
La soluzione arrivò dalla rete.
All'improvviso, io ho scoperto internet
e mi si aprì un mondo.
Alcuni l'hanno scoperto con il porno,
io invece no, io l'ho scoperto scrivendo.
Meglio. Per me, poi non voglio
giudicarvi eh, attenzione.
Io ho cominciato a scrivere.
A scrivere, vabbè, in chat,
a scrivere sui primi social, Messenger
che, vabbè, lo considero un social
anche se era una chat comune,
Myspace, quanti di voi avevano
Myspace all'inizio? Poi dopo
s'è distrutto, a meno che non abbiate
un gruppo che non ascolta nessuno,
perché solo chi non viene ascoltato
ha Myspace adesso, però
Myspace non ce l'avete più.
Io lì ho cominciato a scrivere,
cominciato a sapere che potevo
avere del tempo, che nessuno mi
stava guardando, che nessuno
mi stava aspettando soprattutto.
Quindi io potevo scrivere, rileggere,
capire e inviare.
E cazzo, avevo sbagliato ancora,
però era online, dicevo "Ok Andrea
non ti preoccupare, non se ne accorge
nessuno" e invece no, arrivava gente
che mi prendeva in giro, gente che insomma
si prendeva giuoco di me, poi però
c'erano anche persone che
semplicemente mi dicevano
"guarda, hai invertito queste lettere,
guarda, questi accenti sono sbagliati,
guarda, manca una parola"
e questa cosa mi diede coraggio,
perchè piano piano cominciai a scrivere
sempre di più e mi piaceva farlo.
Mi piaceva raccontare di me,
mi piaceva far sorridere la gente
e lo leggevo dai commenti
che mi lasciavano.
E quindi poi ho aperto anche un blog,
così tanto per dire.
Cosa impossibile se pensiamo
a qualche anno prima
con tutti i piccoli problemi
esistenziali che avevo.
E cominciando a scrivere, la cosa che
ti piace di più, le prime volte,
è difficile speigarlo perché tutti voi
sicuramente non avete provato
questa frustrazione, io non so se
c'è qualche dislessico qua,
però quando cominci a scrivere e
cominci a prenderti il tuo tempo,
senti che lo puoi fare, senti che c'è
qualcuno che ti sta ascoltando,
senti quel qualcuno che
non ti sta giudicando.
Poi ci sono quelli che ti giudicano,
che ti prendono in giro,
che ti attaccano, ma quello fa lo stesso,
quello tanto ci sono sempre.
Io non mi sentivo colpita dentro,
non mi sentivo ferita,
anche perché in rete per un po'
di tempo sono stata questa.
Io, per molto tempo, mi sono presentata
con questa faccia e con il nome sopra,
questo è un esempio che poi...
ovviamente mi sono rovinata il Facebook
per 60 giorni per farvi vedere
questo esempio perché ho scoperto
che se cambi il nome su Facebook, per 60
giorni poi sei costretto a tenere quello.
Quindi io sarò "Anche no" per 2 mesi,
per colpa vostra, grazie.
Quindi, con questo, non essendo me,
essendo un fake, ho trovato tutto
il coraggio del mondo e
veramente mi sono impegnata,
veramente ho fatto qualcosa.
Ma non è finita qui.
Perché lì era semplicemente trovare
un coraggio nel comunicare.
Poi è arrivato il T9.
Lo so che sembra strano, ma il T9
mi ha svoltato, perché avevo la
possibilità di dare la colpa a qualcuno.
Perché quando scrivi, tutti voi l'avete
fatto almeno una volta nella vita,
lo sappiamo, "acc... scusa Samantha il T9,
guarda, l'ho appena installato"
e non è vero, avevate sbagliato.
E io questa cosa l'ho usata
tantissime volte.
Però mi sentivo meno in colpa,
mi sentivo meno distratta.
Anche perché poi il T9 ti cambia
a cavolo una frase, cioè non è che dà
una logica, quindi questa cosa un po'
veramente mi giustificava
ad essere dislessica.
Anche perché noi dislessici invertiamo
le frasi, invertiamo le lettere,
quindi non può trovare una logica
in quella parola, magari ne cerca una
qualsiasi e quella qualsiasi
è sempre sbagliata.
Quindi con il T9 ho preso un po' di tempo.
Ma dopo il T9, la vera svolta per me,
è stato lo smartphone.
Lo smartphone mi ha aperto il mondo.
Perché lo smartphone mi ha reso felice.
Perché? Perché mi segnava con il rosso
l'errore. Non mi cambiava la parola,
lui mi segnava con il rosso l'errore.
Quindi, immaginatevi, tu scrivi qualcosa,
e qualcuno ti cambia le parole,
quindi non hai tempo di imparare,
però puoi dare la colpa a qualcuno.
Invece scrivi qualcosa, prima di inviare,
controlli e vedi le strisce rosse sotto.
Quindi torni su quella parola, la leggi,
respiri, conti e cerchi di capire
e allora poi la cambi.
Ma la puoi cambiare e la puoi sbagliare
un milione di volte. Veramente, la puoi
sbagliare in continuazione e questa cosa
fa la differenza, perché non c'è nessuno
che si annoia, perché un problema mio,
poi non so se tutti i dislessici del mondo
io questa cosa non la posso sapere,
l'ansia che mi saliva era che non capivo
e sapevo che quello davanti a me
e che mi stava spiegando, che mi stava
cercando di far leggere, che mi stava
aspettando, si stava annoiando.
Ed è terribile. E infatti è anche
per quello che ho parlato molto veloce
per un lungo periodo della mia vita
e nessuno mi capiva. Fino ad adesso
ad arrivare a fare qualche pausa
per darvi la possibilità di capire meglio
quello che dico.
Ok, abbiamo parlato dello smartphone
e lo smartphone mi ha aiutato anche a
capire delle regole semplicissime,
che tipo questa,
voi la sapete tutti, ovviamente.
Io l'ho scoperta 4/5 anni fa,
quando ho cominciato a leggere qualsiasi
cosa mi capitasse per le mani,
addirittura, prendevo i treni Roma-Milano,
il mio ragazzo purtroppo lo sa,
giusto per rimanere da sola e poter
leggere, avere delle scuse.
Ho speso dei soldi inutilmente, però
ho scoperto, grazie ai social, grazie allo
smartphone, che il primo "perché" è
sbagliato perché è "perchè" e non va bene,
il secondo invece è giusto.
Ora io non voglio chiedere l'onestà a voi,
chi lo sapeva? Alzi la mano chi lo sapeva,
non mentite, non fati i fighi adesso.
Alzi la mano... Eh, meno della metà.
Vi ho insegnato qualcosa eh?
Scusate, scusate.
Vabbè, vado a concludere perché non voglio
tediarvi oltre, anche perché sto parlando
italiano quindi vedo che qua
parlate tutti benissimo l'inglese
e non vorrei annoiarvi.
È molto urgente, è fondamentale anzi,
direi, che si riesca a capire
se un bambino è affetto da dislessia,
semplicemente, se un bambino ha
un problema, subito, non bisogna
aspettare che arrivi a 18/19, ma anche
soltanto che arrivi ai 10/15, subito,
appena inizia le scuole,
ci sono i test, si può fare qualcosa,
si può cercare d'aiutarli davvero,
aiutarmi, vabbè ormai il tempo è passato
per me, però io sarei stata molto felice
e sarebbe utile che tutti i professori,
le maestre, anzi, imparassero due modi di
insegnare. Perché un modo funziona
e va bene, ma l'altro no.
In Italia, noi dislessici, siamo il 5%,
che sono un botto il 5%,
l'ho detta in modo giovane.
Sono tantissimi il 5%, non sono pochi,
sono davvero tanti.
Quindi perché una persona non può
imparare, anzi, purtroppo perde
delle occasioni, io sono stata testarda,
ho avuto dei genitori che m'hanno aiutato,
ma potevo perdere delle occasioni,
potevo non essere felice come sono
felice adesso. Quindi per quale motivo
non si inizia dall'inizio?
E poi c'è un'altra cosa,
che è anche il motivo per cui sono qua,
e ci tenevo ad essere qua,
che è importantissimo che i professori,
le maestre, ma che soprattutto i genitori
imparino ad usare la rete.
È davvero importante, perché la rete
a me m'ha salvato la vita,
m'ha reso una persona contenta,
una persona felice, una persona combattiva
perché mi sono data il tempo, io,
imparando a studiare da sola,
imparando a cercare quello che
mi interessava, prendendo il mio tempo,
me lo sono data io da sola.
Però se qualcuno me lo poteva spiegare
un po' prima, non perdevo tutto
questo tempo, non mi sentivo
così male per così tanti anni. La rete ci
è amica, la rete ci può dare tantissimo.
Ad esempio gli audiolibri,
a me davvero mi hanno fatto
recuperare tanto di quel tempo che
non ve lo sto neanche a raccontare
perché io tutti i libri che
c'hanno dato alle medie,
purtroppo, li avevo persi,
non ce la facevo.
E poi un'altra domanda:
vi siete mai chiesti per quale motivo
in rete ci sono così tanti siti dove
porre delle domande in modo anonimo?
Ad esempio:
"Qual è il sinonimo di sinonimo?"
Questa è una domanda "x",
qualcuno ha anche sorriso.
"Se niente si incolla al teflon, come
hanno fatto ad incollarlo nelle padelle?"
Domanda legittima, perché nessuno
ha la risposta, quindi adesso non fate
quelli che sanno, perché non è vero.
"Perché "abbreviazione" è
una parola così lunga?"
Eh, perché?
O sennò: "Perché "separato" si scrive
tutto insieme, mentre "tutto insieme"
si scrive separato?"
State ridendo, state ridendo,
non avreste risposto vero?
non avreste perso 5/6 minuti per
dare una risposta a queste persone
che magari davvero lo volevano sapere.
Però la rete l'ha fatto.
Noi no, però la rete l'ha fatto.
E la rete siamo noi.
Però noi no, ma la rete sì.
Quindi la rete è più paziente di noi.
Impariamo ad usarla.
Grazie
(Applausi)